tian bonjour alors une journée d'action
importantes quelles sont vraiment les
attentes
[Musique]
en fait les syndicats la cgt fo la cfdt
unsa tous les syndicats de l'usiné se
sont aujourd'hui rassemblés ce matin ils
sont extrêmement inquiet il demande 1
sans cesse le maintien de tous les
emplois
2500 salariés travaillent actuellement
sur ce site
or les annonces de la direction de
renault qui prévoit comme vous le disiez
un plan d'économies et de
restructuration prévoit de supprimer
1000 postes alors comment et bien selon
les désirs de la direction de parler
d'émissions les départs volontaires les
reclassements
mais c'est plus simple à dire qu'à faire
donc à les salariés très inquiet on fait
un premier jour de grève la semaine
dernière le 11 juin au soir et ils se
sont rassemblés ici peut-être jusqu'à 15
heures en tout cas ils vont essayer de
faire débrayer les autres salariés dans
les dents lusine et je suis actuellement
avec fabien gâche qui est délégué
central renault cgt et il va nous nous
parlait cette situation alors monsieur
gage que souhaitez-vous aujourd'hui
parce que vous allez rencontrer la
direction le 29 juin
mais d'ici là vous êtes très inquiet et
que souhaitez vous on est inquiet parce
que le projet qui était présenté hier
aux organisations syndicales et aux élus
du comité central prévoit la fin de
l'activité de montage de véhicules sur
le site de flins ce qui veut dire que
renault s'interdit dans l'avenir de
fabriquer en france des moteurs des
voitures populaires de segments a et b
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya des
conséquences sociales avec des milliers
de suppressions d'emplois qui vont se
répercuter d'abord pour les intérimaires
qui sont pas comptabilisés dans les 4600
qui vont se répercuter chez des
équipementiers les fournisseurs et qui
vont s'ajouter aux 25 sur vingt-cinq
mille suppressions d'emplois corneau
connaît depuis 2004 c'est dramatique sur
le plan social et nous on considère que
si le projet n'est pas remis en cause
aujourd'hui
si renault ne se dote pas d'une
plateforme électrique construite sur l'
usine de flins c'est l'avenir même de
renault qui est compromis
alors que que répondez-vous aux
arguments de renault qui est dois vous
dire évidemment que la demande n'est
plus aussi forte en voiture et qui ferez
alizés des économies et soupèse
carrément fermé renault tout coup non
mais les arguments de renault en fait
sont assez simples ils sont les mêmes
que l'on entend depuis 20 ans c'est à
dire un seul objectif c'est des niveaux
de rentabilité toujours plus important
d'avoir une marge opérationnelle de 7%
qui est descendu à 4 8 et qui pour eux
justifient de nouvelles restructurations
nous on pense que c'est suicidaire parce
que renault en se coupant d'une usine
comme celle de flins ça veut dire que
renault s'ampute quelque part de sa
capacité à fabriquer en france des
véhicules populaires qui répondent aux
besoins des populations françaises qui
répondent aux enjeux environnementaux et
qui va aussi frappé très durement une
nouvelle fois la filière automobile
française
donc finalement du point de vue
économique c'est un suicide pour renault
mais c'est aussi un suicide pour les
collectivités locales et les
collectivités en règle générale la
direction a laissé entendre que d'autres
activités elle être implémentée sur le
site qui a en effet fait travailler
beaucoup moins de salariés et qu'elles
sont l est est ce que vous y croyez
alors les les activités qui ont été
présentés qui serait censée compenser la
fin du montage de véhicules
personne aujourd'hui ne peut croire
qu'elles permettront d'occuper les 1600
salariés qu'ils seraient censés rester
sur le site d'une part d'autre part les
activités notamment des véhicules
d'occasion qui serait retraités ici mais
sont des activités qui existe déjà et
qui sont faites dans d'autres
établissements de renault notamment dans
le réseau commercial
donc en fait c'est des emplois d'un côté
que l'on enlève à d'autres pour les
mettre ici et là et là et le volume de
ses activités là de toute façon ne
peuvent pas à moyens ils ont été encore
moins long terme
occuper autant de salariés sur un site
aussi grand merci fabien gâche donc vous
voyez des syndicalistes très inquiet
aujourd'hui qui se sont réunis en masse
un jeu qui ont ils sont plusieurs
centaines à avoir démarré cette grève
pour exiger le maintien de tous les
emplois sachant que la plateforme de
flins à terme est censé ne plus produire
la zoé et la nissan alors et 2024
katia merci pour toutes ces précisions